Hi, if you are in 10th,
your marks in 10th exam are good in new science,
then should we not take science?
No, you cannot decide on the basis of marks alone whether
you want to become an engineer
or a doctor, you have to see whether you want to become an engineer or a doctor.
What is the target? Are you
seeing yourself alone after 5 years or 6 years
or are you seeing yourself being a doctor
or if you are
seeing neither of the two? Are you wondering whether
I am interested?  I do
n't like science at all,
reading chemistry, studying physics, reading maths,
reading bio here, so I am
not going to take science subject after 10th, I am going to take it,
but do not judge yourself on the basis of marks, do
not think that
If we get more marks in science then we will
take science and if we get less marks then we will
not take science. Don't do this mistake I hope it is
happy learning.